I don't get invited to a lot of parties
but when I get invited to parties if
somebody says
what do you do for a living and I say
I'm a divorce lawyer and they go oh my
God you must have stories that's the way
everybody's oh my God you must have so
many stories
and if I said yeah there was this couple
and they you know slowly grew apart and
then they decided that it would be good
for them to end their relationship as a
married couple but they wanted to
continue to have an amicable
co-parenting relationship so they
divided their assets and and they
figured out a good parenting access
schedule that made sure that they both
had both Leisure Time and
responsibilities with the children
people would be like that's the worst
story yeah that's so boring yeah
so what they really want is the like and
then he was sleeping with the nanny and
then she caught him so you know the
truth is like people want to hear about
those flame outs and by the way those
are super interesting as a lawyer like
it's super
interesting it's usually going to be
what infidelity you do have a chapter
called everybody the nanny
everybody's The Nanny everybody
he's a nanny Fascination out there I try
to explain it in the book but yeah I
mean I've had some great Nanny stories I
mean people run off with the nanny
people end up getting married to the
nanny I had one where the the he
convinced her that they should have a
threesome with the nanny they got the
nanny drunk they had a bunch of
threesomes with the nanny and then the
nanny and the wife
paired up and left him oh nice and
they're still quite happy that seems
like a happy ending for everyone but him
but it was his idea well he's really
gonna have a nanny Fascination now now
he's yeah well now he's got to see the
nanny who's now the like step parents to
the kids and it was his bright idea of
let's have a threesome with the nanny
you know yeah I mean the nanny thing I I
think is a function of in many
circumstances is the characteristics of
the wife
that
he remembers fondly
and that have been extinguished by the
presence of children
so I I my words of wisdom is not don't
get a nanny or make sure you get an ugly
Nanny my my thought on it is that a
woman should remember even when she's a
mother that she's also a woman who a man
you know they fell in love with each
other and she should take time to be in
touch with the part of herself that is
an independent woman that's interesting
and interested and you know like there's
a lot to be learned from divorced
couples because like divorced couples if
you do it right
it's awesome like I I had a wonderful
experience parenting and being divorced
because I divorced when my kids were
quite young my co-parent you know my
ex-wife is awesome she's a great mom
nice person we're good friends and it
was great I had half the time I had my
kids and I could focus on them and the
other half of the time they were with
the other person who loves them as much
as I do and I didn't have any of the
responsibilities of of kids and I could
just have you know all of the wonderful
fun that you can have when you don't
have you know the the responsibilities
that come with full-time caring for
children